Hi everybody.
Uh,
I guess I'm the one that gets,
did,
do the introduction here.
So we were just talking a little while ago about how science fiction in
particular is a genre with a couple of competing,
uh,
qualities about it.
On one hand,
good science fiction is about,
you know,
the time and place it's written,
not,
you know,
thousands of year in the future,
but on the other hand,
you're not supposed to think.
So while you're reading it,
I,
and the author that you're here to see today,
I am lucky is extremely good at both sides of that coin.
Right?
So let's hear her talk about her new book.
Okay.
Oh,
hello.
It's good to see everybody here.
Look at you all.
This is wonderful.
Um,
I guess I'll start,
uh,
if everybody is agreeable with the reading a little bit from the new book.
Yeah.
Uh,
so this book is in a lot of ways,
uh,
it's set in the same universe as the trilogy,
but it's a rather different from the trilogy.
I felt like I needed kind of a break from that intensity.
Uh,
and so I wanted to write something a little more of a romp,
a something a little more relaxing after that.
Uh,
so,
uh,
I'm going to start not at the very beginning,
but a little in and,
uh,
what's happening is the main character in gray,
she has spent literally every space penny she has,
uh,
trying to,
spring and notorious criminal from the euphemistically named prison,
compassionate release,
compassionate removal.
Please excuse me.
Uh,
and uh,
she has done this and this person has been delivered to her in a crate in a
suspension pod,
uh,
which in some ways is a relief to her because she doesn't have to explain what
she's doing to them quite yet.
Uh,
and,
uh,
she's taken the crate to the ship that she has booked to take her back home and
the captain,
uh,
is having none of it.
He does not want to take anyone,
a board who is not like conscious and able to say,
yes,
I want to go somewhere.
Right.
Captain Nuzeen stared at her over the crate.
Okay,
I am on the very edge.
He said finally of refunding your passage,
both of the births you've paid for and asking you to leave this bay.
I haven't made up my mind yet,
but I'll tell you one thing.
There's no way you're bringing that person.
Paula Boudreaux came.
You said a board my ship still in that suspension pod and considering you
expected to meet him awaken on frozen,
you won't have any objection to throwing 'em out now I presume.
Okay.
Will you take us aboard then I'll consider taking you a board then Paula
Boudreaux Keem can do as he likes.
A moment's thought.
If he doesn't want to come aboard,
I'll refund you are fair.
It could've been in race opposed.
It was some sort of chance.
Anyway,
captain is Iin.
Put his other hand on the crate.
Step back.
Excellency,
you don't want your foot caught under this in gray.
Stepped back in the crate,
settled to the floor with a funk.
Do you know if this person has ever been in suspension before in gray?
Picked up her jacket and bag and sandals off the crate lid.
No.
Why?
Captain is Iin.
Touched the crates,
latches and carefully slid the lid aside.
He might panic if he doesn't know what to expect.
A little help would be nice in grade,
dropped her sandals and bag,
pulled her jacket on and then helped brace the lid as captain Dezeen tilted it
and let it slide down to rest against the crate.
Captain is he and looked for a moment at the smooth black surface of the pod.
Then slid open the pods control panel.
Everything looks good.
He said as a giant black spiders scuttled out of the airlock.
Nearly a meter high.
A rolled up blanket clutched in one Harry appendage.
Weirdly,
disturbingly graceful.
It's skittered up to captain as iin and stopped.
Turned one of it's far too many stock dies toward in gray.
No,
it wasn't a spider.
It was something else.
Um,
setting gray.
That's is that a spider?
She didn't know why the back of her neck was prickling.
She didn't mind spiders,
but this thing was so unsettling.
It's legs were jointed wrong.
She realized,
and it's,
I stock sprouted right out of its blob of a body.
There was no waste,
no head,
and something else was wrong though.
She couldn't quite see what.
Of course,
it's not a spider replied captain busines still frowning at the suspension pod.
You don't get spiders with half meter bodies are two meter legs bans or you
know,
not an augmented ones,
but this isn't a spider.
He looked up,
but it's kind of like a spider.
I'll grant you that.
Do you have a problem with spiders?
Excellency?
They're not.
Spider's body trembled.
Gelatinous Lee stretched to become oblong rather than round and for extra legs
lit out to touch the bay floor.
Does that help?
Seeing the thing change shape was somehow even more disturbing,
but she refused to step back even though she wanted to.
Not really.
And I don't mind spiders at all.
It's just this looks so,
so organic except in a wrong,
squishy,
itchy sort of way.
Well,
yes.
Said Captain Dezeen Standing Square,
install it by the open crate entirely unbothered by the spidery thing beside
him.
A lot of it is.
Some people find it unsettling and apparently you're one of them,
but it's just a Biomek.
You'll get used to it after a few days or if you don't,
I'll keep it out of your way.
He touched the control panel and the smooth surface of the pod broke open with a
click and slit aside for just an instant in gray,
saw a person lying naked and motionless.
Submerged in a pool of blue fluid unevenly cut hair,
a tangled mass over half of our sharp featured face,
thin,
thinner than she remembered.
Pictures of Pallet Boudreaux came the long well to the scar along your right
flank.
Then the smooth glossy surface of the preserving medium rippled and below it is
the person opened their eyes and sat convulsively up choking one out thrust arms
smacking hard into in gray,
captain newsy and grabbed her other arm.
It's all right.
He said,
boy,
still calm and serious.
The person continued to choke as blue fluid poured out of your mouth and nose.
She did away from your body back into the pod.
It's all right.
Everything's fine.
You're all right.
Okay.
The last of the fluid drained away from the person's mouth and nose.
Any gave a breathy shaking moan first time as captain azine reaching down for
the blanket,
the spider Mac still proffered the naked person in the pod closed.
Her eyes gasped a few times and then our breathing settled.
Are you all right?
Asked in gray in volunteer this time.
The most commonly spoken language in waste system though she was fairly sure
Pallette Boudreaux came would have understood year,
which captain nuzeen had used.
Okay.
Captain oozine shook the blanket out and laid it around the naked person's
shoulders.
Okay.
Where am I?
He asked in [inaudible] voice.
Rough with cold or fear or something else.
Yeah,
we're on Tier Sila station in tier system setting.
Ray and then to captain nuzeen.
He asked where he is and I told him we're on [inaudible].
Okay.
How did I get here?
As the person sitting in the suspension pod in [inaudible] by now,
the blue fluid had all drained away to some reservoir in the pod itself.
Yeah.
I paid someone to bring you out setting gray.
I'm in gray.
Out schooled.
Okay.
The person opened their eyes then
who?
Well in gray had never really met.
Paula Boudreaux came in person and he was 10 or more years older than she was
and not likely to have noticed a very young oak gold foster daughter.
Not Likely to have known her name when she had still been a child,
let alone her adult name,
which she'd taken only months before he'd gone to compassionate removal.
Yeah,
I'm one of Natano [inaudible] children sitting in gray.
Okay.
Why he asked or voice gaining strength would one of representatives,
our schools,
children bring me anywhere.
Okay.
In grade,
tried to think of a simple way to explain and settled.
Finally for your palate,
Beaudry came,
it gave a little shake of your head,
a frown.
Who
in race suppressed to start is another spider.
Mac came skittering out of the airlock.
This one held a large cup of steaming liquid,
which it passed to captain is before it spun and returned to the ship here.
Excellency,
he said in year offering it to the person's still sitting in the pod.
Can you hold this here?
Said the first spider Mac in a thin thready voice in [inaudible].
Can you hold this?
Yeah.
Orange.
You Paula Boudreaux.
Keem asked in gray feeling strangely numb except maybe for an unpleasant
sensation in her gut as though she was not capable of feeling any more despair
or fear than she already had today.
The facilitator had said this was Palade.
No,
it said it examined the payment and the merchandise and both were what they
should have been,
but surely that was the same thing.
No.
Said the person sitting in the suspension pod,
I don't even know who that is.
He noticed the Cup captain is Ian was proffering thank you.
He said and took it.
Cup did in our hands as captain azine stopped the blanket from sliding off your
shoulders.
Drink.
Some said captain busines still in year.
It's Serb at.
It'll do you good drink.
It said the spider Mech and Vania.
It's served at.
It's good.
A nutritious.
What if there had been a mistake?
This person looked like Paula [inaudible] team,
but also in a way he didn't.
He was thinner.
Certainly an ingrate had only seen him in person once or twice,
and that was years ago.
You're not politic woodworking?
No.
Said the person who was not Paulette Boudreaux Keem I already said that he took
a drink of the Serb bat.
Oh,
that's good.
Really.
It didn't matter.
Even if this person was Palade,
if he was lying to her,
it made no difference.
She couldn't compel him to go with her back to way and not just because captain
is iin would refuse to take them unless he wanted to go.
Her plan had always depended on Paula being willing to go along.
You look a lot like Paula Boudreaux.
Keem in gray said,
still hoping do.
I asked and took another drink of surveys that I guess someone made a mistake.
He looked straight at in gray then and said,
so when a Buddha Keem goes to compassionate removal is only for show,
is it?
They send someone to fish them out behind the scenes.
Air Expression didn't change,
but her voice was bitter in grade.
Dude drew breath to say indignantly.
No,
of course not,
but found herself struck speechless by the fact that she had herself gotten a
Beaudry key amount of compassionate removal.
No,
she managed finally.
I,
you're really not poet Boudreaux came.
I'm really not.
He said then who are you as the spider Mac?
They'll captain Dezeen hadn't said anything.
Allowed the person sitting in the suspension pod took another drink of survey
then said,
you said we're onto your seal us.
Yes.
Said the spider Mac in gray found she couldn't speak at all.
I think I'd rather not tell you who I am.
He looked around at the suspension party,
sat in the crates,
still surrounding it at Captain Dezeen at the spider Mac beside the captain
around the bay.
I think I'd like to visit the incomers office.
Why asked in gray?
Almost a cry.
Unable to keep her confusion and her despair out of her voice.
Unless you have financial resources were unaware of said the spider Mac.
You won't be able to do more than apply for an indenture.
You may or may not get one.
And unless you have contacts here,
you very probably won't like what you get.
If you do,
I'll like it better than compassionate removal.
He drained the last of our beverage.
Look on the bright side.
Captain is Ean,
said himself to Ian Gray in year as he took the cup from not Paula,
I'll refund you or passage and you'll be able to eat actual food for the next
couple of days.
Oh,
so,
uh,
usually at this stage I take questions.
Sometimes I say a,
I could maybe sing and dance,
but I'm very bad at those things.
So,
uh,
if anyone has any questions,
I know there are mics in the aisles there and a,
I will be happy to answer questions or talk about whatever people would like me
to talk about.
All right.
This is kind of a generic question,
but like what does your like writing setup look like?
And you know,
what do you do when you,
you know,
find it hard to write or kind of stuck creatively?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
my,
I have a couple of places that I tend to write a,
I have a nice little office in the basement that my husband put together for me.
Uh,
I have two nice big monitors,
which are the best for editing,
uh,
and,
a nice ergonomic keyboard,
which I love my ergonomic keyboard.
Uh,
sometimes that doesn't suit where I'm at.
so I will take a laptop out to the back porch or to a coffee shop or whatever.
Um,
when I'm stuck very often I will spend an hour or two,
like basically banging my head on the desk,
uh,
trying to figure out where the sentences are that need to come.
Uh,
and then very often I'll give up and go upstairs to take a shower and there's
something in the shower water.
Usually that's when I realized what I needed to have written a,
if that doesn't work,
I will go for a walk.
And if the walk doesn't work,
I know it's time to go to the library where I will just walk down the history
and anthropology shelves and pull off anything that seems appealing.
And nine times out of 10,
that first stack of books will have something in it.
That was what I was looking for.
Cool.
Thank you.
Hi.
Uh,
could you talk about your decision to use the specific pronouns rather than the
female pronoun?
Ah,
well I do use,
I do use she in this book,
uh,
but not default,
right.
As I,
as I do in the trilogy,
uh,
I'm very proud about my choice in the trilogy.
Uh,
I'm really pleased with the effects that it had.
but I also,
uh,
listening to conversations about that,
among other people.
Uh,
some folks pointed out that that usage,
while it does cool things also sort of erases a bunch of different identities.
Uh,
and I said that's an interesting point and maybe I want to think some more about
that.
So,
uh,
when it came to this book,
is very much like the trilogy.
It's very much not what the book is about.
But I said,
what if I had a society that doesn't think of gender as being obviously a
binary?
The way our culture tends to think of it.
Uh,
this society thinks,
obviously there are three genders,
right?
There are men,
women and Nemon.
Uh,
and it's a he and she,
and he and I chose this Vivec pronouns in particular because there are lots to
choose from.
There are just many that folks have suggested and come up with.
Uh,
and,
uh,
but as it happens,
I actually know some who use those as their pronouns.
And I thought,
well,
that'll be kind of fun because then they'll get to open the book and say,
Oh,
look,
there's my pronouns.
Right.
Being used.
There's people there who I could think of are,
are like me in a way.
I mean,
I probably don't capture their identities because that's a complicated thing.
Uh,
but it's kind of,
it's so rewarding and important to be able to see that on the page.
So that's why I made that specific choice.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Um,
I know that lots of,
some authors have talked about how they write very out of order.
While I've,
I've heard some who were able to write more,
uh,
in line and I was curious how that goes for you.
Are you,
are you,
uh,
in line with the uh,
timeline or is it all over the place?
I pretty much can't write out of order.
I haven't been able to write out of order,
uh,
partly because I don't outline,
and very often,
although I do have an idea of where I'm going with the story,
I know where I want to end up.
I often know some signposts,
but the specifics of how a scene works,
I can't envision until I've got what comes before it.
Uh,
because so many tiny little nuances of conversation or action will inform that
next scene.
Uh,
so then it,
I don't have any ground to write the next scene from.
So,
uh,
I have never been able to write very much out of order at all.
I'm very envious of my friends who outlined very,
a very,
at a very detailed level.
They write so much faster than I do.
Uh,
but,
and one of these days,
maybe I'll manage it,
but I've never been able to do it.
Yeah.
To what extent,
if any did in m Banks's culture series and their ascension ships sort of
influence,
uh,
you know,
your choice to sort of feed Sherif ascension ship has a protagonist and the
insularity trilogy
actually not at all because I had not read banks until I was very far along in
ancillary justice.
Uh,
when I did read banks,
I was like,
this is awesome and I love that there's actually like,
somebody will buy stories with,
sent you the chips.
Right.
Um,
but,
uh,
my work frequently gets compared to banks,
which is a tremendous compliment but not a particularly accurate assessment of
my influences.
Yeah.
Every writer we'll like choose some parts of the world to focus on and pay less
attention to other parts.
In your work,
I noticed you use a lot of,
you know,
off the shelf Scifi technology,
um,
shuttle.
We'll get your lively from one place to another,
but you don't relate,
dwell on how it works,
the cracks,
it will heal an injury.
Um,
was that a conscious decision to focus less on the attack,
more on the social aspects or whatever?
Can you talk about your thought process there?
Uh,
it very much was a conscious decision.
in some cases actually I've worked out for myself what my rationalization is for
some of the sort of magic tech.
Uh,
but I feel like that's not the focus of the stories as such.
I like working with the implications of it more than with the actual details of
the tech.
Uh,
so,
so yeah,
that was definitely a conscious choice.
How fast do you write?
It really depends.
Ideally,
in theory,
I write at least a thousand words a day.
That's ideally,
uh,
some days I can do much more than that.
Some days I'm lucky to get five words.
Uh,
some days I'm in the stage of creating where actually what I need to do is read
and think.
And no words are coming at all.
And those days are very scary and frustrating,
but I've discovered that they're an important part of the process because it
doesn't move forward without those days.
Yeah.
So is it radically different when you're actively working on a book versus,
you know,
breaks in between?
Oh,
absolutely.
Very,
very different.
Um,
and I can,
when I'm between large projects,
I will go a month or two without having written anything at all and then I'll
get super paranoid and have to remind myself that actually it'll be okay.
Yeah.
I'm actually still working on something even if there aren't words.
So I'm,
I'm delighted to be back in the,
in the same universe and especially in a different part of it.
I haven't read the book yet.
Um,
w when I got to the end of the trilogy,
I was a little distraught at the,
at the idea that I might never actually find out what's going on inside the
Dyson sphere that's in the middle of everything.
Um,
and I'm wondering like,
you know,
do you know how much of the of the map of this university are eventually going
to write about?
And will we see the inside of that Dyson sphere with the gloves off at some
point in the future or,
um,
clubs off that's very improper.
Uh,
um,
I obviously know a lot more about the Dyson sphere than ever ended up on the
page.
Right.
Uh,
as to whether or not I'll write about it.
I might,
uh,
I have to admit I'm easily bored.
Uh,
and I'm in a place right now where I'm fortunate to be able to just take off
after whatever's shiny.
Uh,
and so if that feels shiny to me,
I might,
uh,
so I don't know for sure there aren't concrete plans to do it,
but there aren't concrete plans not to as well.
So I make no promises.
So in terms of your influences in fiction,
what are your influences outside of science fiction
outside of science fiction?
Oh,
the inside of science fiction as much easier to answer,
isn't it?
Uh,
I honestly don't know.
well,
I do a,
I do read quite a lot of,
uh,
history and anthropology almost at random.
Uh,
I find that a real human cultures are more varied and nuanced than anything I
could ever put on the page.
Uh,
and if I want to create something realistic,
uh,
I can't go wrong by looking at what already exists.
Uh,
in history of course is full of amazing stories that often don't end up in
school because there's,
you know,
you don't hear about them when you're taking your western Civ course or
whatever.
Uh,
and there's just some amazing stuff to use their,
uh,
so I will read things like that.
Uh,
I also find,
uh,
I really enjoy historical fiction for some similar reasons.
Uh,
when I'm not working on a,
on a project in particular,
often I will go and read like some very light historical romances just as kind
of a mental break.
I don't know how much those influenced my,
uh,
my writing.
Uh,
I do know,
uh,
when the second book in the trilogy came out and,
a bunch of people were like,
wow,
this is really weird.
It's very different from the first book.
And it was one person in particular who DMD me and said,
you know what?
This really reminds me of this Patrick O'bryan.
Okay,
nice.
And actually I main lines that entire series right before I sat down to write
this.
So
influences come in odd places.
Yeah.
So it's influences within science fiction is easier.
What are your influences within science fiction?
So the obvious answers,
uh,
to influences within science fiction would be as a child,
I read way more Andre Norton that could possibly be healthy for a single person.
Uh,
I suspect that Norton is a writer who she doesn't get talked about very much
critically.
Uh,
but I suspect she's had a profound impact on the field because a lot of us grew
up reading her work.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I'm,
I couldn't point to where,
but I don't doubt that her work has influenced mine very strongly.
Uh,
also,
uh,
especially in the past 10 or 15 years,
I have become a huge CJ cherry fan girl.
Uh,
those of you who,
who's another writer who's a major figure in the field and maybe doesn't get
talked about as much.
Uh,
I mentioned her at every opportunity because I think that should probably change
a,
those of you who have read her foreign or series,
which I love,
it's up to what,
18 books now.
Um,
we'll probably have noticed there are actually some deliberate Easter eggs in
the trilogy that are deliberate hat tips to Cj Cherry.
Uh,
uh,
I just,
I love her work so much.
I also,
uh,
when I was first starting out,
seriously writing,
uh,
and I realized my visuals left something to be desired,
I went back and reread a large amount of Jack Vance who's work I just admired
tremendously on a sentence level,
uh,
just beautiful writing a really gorgeous visuals and are a real,
almost sort of anthropological knack for,
uh,
creating tiny little sort of some nail sketches of bizarre human cultures that
feel absolutely real where you say,
wow,
that's really weird.
And I totally believe that human beings would do that.
It needs,
or just little like little sort of decorations along the way.
Just sort of ornamental stuff.
Uh,
his work is really fabulous.
You talked about when you just mentioned,
you know,
when you first started seriously writing,
and so was there when you're writing a first book,
like is there a moment that you sort of go from,
this is something I'm doing to,
this is going to be a trilogy in a universe.
Like how do you,
how do you get from not writer to writer?
Like,
what is,
was that transition like what was that transition like for you?
Like it's,
it's,
it's almost one of those things where you suddenly look up and realize that
you've passed a transition.
Right.
Um,
and I'm going to be flipped and it also not flip and say the way that you become
a writer is to write that sound.
It's like not a helpful answer.
And if when I was at the stage where I was a beginning writer and a writer would
say,
the way you become a writer to write and be like,
oh,
thanks.
Right.
Uh,
I didn't know that.
but it actually does.
Uh,
what I,
what happened with me and I think is fairly typical as I have actually written
two or three other novels,
uh,
that no one in this room will ever see because they are dreadful.
Um,
and uh,
and they're,
they're put away in a drawer.
But that was part of the process.
So that by the time I came to ancillary justice,
I had already built up a level of skill and confidence that I was able to say,
oh,
this is going to be a trilogy.
Before I started to write a,
I didn't say that about my first novel,
partly because it was a nano rhyme on novel.
And partly because I was just,
I had no idea what I was doing.
Uh,
and uh,
and it just kinda comes with time and continuing to do it.
If you're going to be a writer,
you kind of have to be sort of bloody minded about it.
Uh,
because you're not going to get validation from outside.
You're not going to get,
barring certain special circumstances.
You're not going to get a certificate that says,
now you're a writer,
uh,
and you can do everything right and write the most beautiful,
gorgeous work and never have much in the way of success.
Uh,
there's no,
so it's just,
you just have to sit down and do it.
And after a while you do it long enough that it's sort of part of what you're
doing right.
And you say,
Oh,
now I'm a writer.
Yeah.
So you,
you said earlier that you don't,
you know,
plot or outline too far ahead.
So then how do you know that this is going to be a trilogy and not to books or
four books or 10 books?
Huh.
I knew where the trilogy was going to end up.
I knew where the trilogy was headed and I knew I couldn't do that in one novel.
Uh,
but the only,
the only specific signposts I had where for the first novel,
like a couple of scenes that I knew I wanted to hit a,
if I look too far ahead,
it would just become way too daunting.
And that's,
you know,
it's like you're up outside of a hundred story building,
like don't look down.
Right.
You can't do that.
Uh,
so,
uh,
so that's basically,
I can't start writing unless I know where I want to end up.
So that was how that happened.
Yeah.
Yes.
There was a kind of like,
you hit some point and you're like,
okay,
this is enough words for a first book or enough progression in the plot.
Somewhere in between.
It's a little bit more,
uh,
once I say to myself,
this is a trilogy,
right?
Then I say,
uh,
then I said to myself,
than I need to make,
each book has its own arc,
right?
Because I think they should be illegal.
Actually,
you know,
when you pick up a book and you read it,
it's the first in a series and it ends on a cliffhanger and the next book's not
out till next year.
That should be illegal straight up.
And I understand why it happens,
especially when you've got a really big work and the publisher is like,
yeah,
this is too big for one volume.
Let's split it in half.
It should still be illegal.
Um,
so,
uh,
so I said,
well,
I know it's a trilogy,
but I also know that I can write and write and maybe never even sell the first
volume.
So I'm going to carve out a story that's itself,
that's complete,
but also that can go on to the rest of the trilogy that I wanted.
And that was what I aimed at.
So,
um,
so something I was wondering about earlier when you were talking about sort of
how many,
how much you write in a day or how many words or whatever,
how much do those words sort of evolve between the first time you put them down
on like a digital page and the book's publication.
And do you ever like go back and change how the details of something worked out
after you write the next parts are
oh yes.
Almost always.
I will often start my days writing with going back over what I wrote the day
before.
Uh,
if nothing else to get kind of a running start on what I did.
but I'll always be like adjusting sentences and changing things.
And it,
of course,
it also happens that like,
I'll be on the shower in the shower and go,
oh my gosh,
five chapters ago,
I need to change this detail.
Right.
And then I'll have to run downstairs and change the thing and hopefully I didn't
drip too much on the keyboard and you know,
uh,
so,
so there is a fair amount of changing,
but I also,
uh,
I do work very slowly moving ahead.
Uh,
so I don't do quite as much ripping out and completely changing things as I did
when I first started out.
When I first turned out I was nano rhyming.
Right.
So it was like plunge right ahead.
Don't stop,
don't think,
just keep typing.
And that made for a lot of,
yeah,
that whole,
you know,
60 pages has to go right.
So A,
I'm a lot more careful,
but there,
there's always lots of tweaking and adjusting and deleting and adding.
I have a question about sense and nonsense.
Maybe pseudoscience made mainly the,
uh,
the press corps translators and the tech ambassador.
I is that hard to write fun to write both?
It's both.
That was,
they were so fun to write.
I loved riding them.
I knew that they were going to be kind of absurd.
But when translated leaky came on stage and the,
and uttered her first couple lines and then I was like,
oh,
this is going somewhere really weird.
And I was like,
yeah,
I'm just going to lean into that.
Right.
And it was a lot of fun.
Uh,
and actually,
uh,
I guess this is potential spoilers.
Uh,
I was,
when I realized how brief a time she was going to be on stage,
uh,
I was very unhappy and I said,
well,
I'm just going to have to change this.
And I tried to change it and it was going to break the book.
Uh,
and I said,
I can't do it.
So I said,
well,
when in the third book,
I know translators Ayotte's coming,
so I'm going to have her on stage every minute I can and get all the fun.
I cannot have her.
Uh,
so they turned out to be such a delight to write,
but it was also very difficult,
right?
Because that's the kind of thing that you can kind of get wrong if you,
it's like a tight rope.
You step to either side and it falls flat.
Did you find yourself having to get into to a particular mind space to write
them?
Yeah,
kind of.
Yeah.
It was kind of an odd space.
Yeah,
they were a lot of fun.
They were.
I really,
I missed them.
Of,
of all the,
yeah.
Fair enough.
And were there any specific inspirations for those?
Um,
I didn't think there were,
but somebody messaged me at one point and said,
did you read Lloyd Alexandra's Prydain chronicles?
I see you all nodding.
You know exactly you're thinking or do or when an and I said,
oh,
I did.
I loved those books.
I read them so many times.
I have them practically memorized right when I was a kid.
So it's probably that,
that's probably where this came from,
but I was not conscious of that at all.
Which is,
that's kind of the funny way that the things that you read kind of influenced
you without your knowing.
I was wondering if they were a CG cherries,
methane breathers,
but yeah,
there was that too.
Yeah.
Cj Cherries.
Methane breezers are fabulous.
Yeah.
Awesome.
Thanks.
So who sees your stuff while you're writing it?
Do you have a writer's group that you work with?
Do you have Beta readers?
I,
uh,
I used to have a writers group in town and then a couple of people moved out of
town.
Now I have a couple of friends who live in town who when I'm feeling super
insecure,
which totally happens,
like the first couple chapters.
And I'm like,
is this even worth writing?
This is just a thing that writers have,
right?
Uh,
sometimes new writers are like,
this means I'm not any good.
No,
it means you were a writer.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so then I go to them and I go,
these are my first three chapters.
Is this any good?
And they're like,
yeah,
just go finish it.
Right.
Which is what I need to hear.
Uh,
and then I will give them the manuscript and they'll make comments.
I don't always,
and any of y'all who are aspiring fiction writers,
uh,
people who give you comments there were thinking about,
and trying to think about where those comments came from,
but do not just take the advice that they give you because nine times out of 10,
they're wrong.
When they say,
when they say,
oh,
this isn't working,
you need to explain this more.
Actually,
nine times out of 10,
you need to take away the sentence that makes them ask the question.
Or,
uh,
you know,
this character is not realistic and you're like,
but they should be,
there's one tiny sentence like two chapters back that is leading the reader
astray somewhere.
So don't just delete things when your,
your commenters say delete something or whatever.
Uh,
but I find that fairly important,
but I don't rely on it as much as I did when I was just starting out.
Thank you.
Uh,
I wonder,
so as a fairly inexperienced parent,
uh,
I'm wondering how you carve out time and the ability to have complex thoughts
and
how do you do it while there's a tiny human throwing blueberries at you?
It's difficult.
Isn't it?
Or,
uh,
my son had a thing for pushing buttons and plugging and unplugging things
I learned to save frequently.
Yes.
Uh,
it's much easier when they go to school,
which I knew was kind of the cop out answer,
but also to a certain extent,
uh,
I started writing seriously in earnest,
partly because I was home with the children,
uh,
who my children probably like your children were the most adorable small
children in the history of small children.
Right.
I will fight anybody who tells me to the contrary.
Uh,
and it was great to be home with them,
but,
uh,
they did not provide very intellectually stimulating conversation.
Uh,
I could talk all I wanted about Tele Tevyes right.
teletubbies were big in my house,
Barney.
Uh,
but,
uh,
eventually I felt like my brains were leaking out my ears.
And so to a certain extent that kind of thinking about stories,
excuse me,
uh,
was sort of self defense to begin with.
Uh,
I didn't actually do much in the way of writing until my daughter was away at
school during the day and my son could take naps.
My husband worked nights at the time,
and so I would lay my toddler son in bed,
uh,
next to his dad,
and then I would go to Starbucks.
Uh,
and then eventually I came back,
uh,
to,
consistently discover my son playing in the living room by himself,
and then I enrolled him in preschool so that I could continue to write,
uh,
just a couple of hours in the morning.
Uh,
but I'm not going to lie.
It's really hard when you've got the little folks at home because you're lucky
to have a shower by yourself.
Right.
Uh,
and you can't give full attention to other things because those little kids
getting a lot of trouble.
Right?
Yeah.
There was also the keys in the outlet the one day,
I mean,
yeah,
the whole house went dark.
Yeah.
It was amazing.
Um,
and,
and my kids were pretty good kids,
right?
You have to,
but you have to kind of keep track of them.
Uh,
so it's,
it's the most amazing thing when your kid,
when your youngest finally goes to kindergarten,
you're like,
I'm free.
I can actually think about things and do things.
So my advice would be while they're little,
store up,
all the thoughts,
you know,
the random little thoughts that you have,
keep them in a notebook,
keep them in the back of your mind.
Uh,
and then when you do get to the point where the Kiddos are at school or daycare
or whatever,
then take advantage of that time.
Don't,
don't worry about the freaking laundry did anything like that.
Uh,
you know,
the clothes aren't gonna explode if you don't wash them today.
Uh,
so just like walk out of the House and sit down and work on whatever,
uh,
because that's important.
Right?
You need to,
you need to get your brains working back again.
Yeah.
So I haven't read the new book yet,
but I'm kind of curious what percentage of the book is sort of dedicated to
discussion,
preparation and consumption of tea?
I would say 0%,
except there's one character who does arrive and complains that she cannot find
a good cup of tea.
Right.
Uh,
but I wanted very much,
uh,
the,
the other night at a bookstore event,
a person said to me,
you know,
this main character is almost like the complete opposite of Breck.
How much of that was just,
you wanted to write something that was totally unlike the trilogy and I said
pretty much all of it,
right.
So I just,
I was like,
all right,
this is going to be different.
So no t for tagging,
this is going to be very different.
Yeah.
It is ti something you drink a lot of while you're riding?
Oh,
yes.
Tea is something I drink a lot of,
uh,
one of the,
I love traveling and meeting people,
but one of the downsides is it's very difficult to find a good cup of tea while
you're on the road.
Right.
Because it's not a thing that Americans typically,
it's becoming more,
which is awesome.
Tea is kind of becoming more fashionable and you can find more places that serve
it.
Uh,
but hotel rooms do not necessarily provide you with good tea.
So I'm looking forward to getting home and being able to sit down and have a
cup.
Yeah,
yeah.
So I haven't read,
I'm actually any of your work and I'm looking forward to it now.
I'm going to read this one first because it's what,
what's in my hands?
Yeah.
So given what you were just saying about how this is the opposite,
or you were sort of trying to lean the other direction from the previous
trilogy,
when I finish this one,
if I go to pick up your trilogy,
what would you say to prepare me?
Oh,
that's,
so,
uh,
the trilogy is much more serious and intense,
particularly the first book.
The mood is very different and the protagonist is very different and,
uh,
presents a far more in a farmer grim way.
Uh,
so,
uh,
that would probably be the biggest,
the biggest difference.
But other than that,
I think if you enjoy this,
which is meant to be a standalone for precisely that reason,
uh,
you could probably enter into the chilled you pretty easily,
I would imagine.
So.
You're not going to warm me off of it completely.
Oh,
no.
Ha.
Buy and read all my books please.
Yeah.
Okay.
So,
uh,
what are you working on next?
Oh,
I'm not at the,
I am working on a thing,
but I'm not at the point where I really can talk about it yet.
So,
but I will as soon as I can.
So something,
something.
Yeah.
I am working on another book.
Let me put it that way.
Cause if I say I'm working on something,
it sounds like I've got,
I'm working on a movie,
I'm writing comic books.
No,
I,
it's nothing that are shattering.
I am working on another book.
It's just too early to talk about yet.
Yeah.
What is Serbia?
Okay.
What is her back?
So it's not tea,
it's not tea
almost,
but not entirely on late teens
but not entirely unlike t.
There's actually a real world drink.
I named it after,
uh,
there's a,
a drink.
I found it in the international grocery at home called Sir about [inaudible].
Uh,
and it's an instant thing.
it comes in little packets,
uh,
and it's got sugar and like cloves and black pepper and ginger and it makes a
nice little hot drink.
And I said,
well,
okay,
it's not t and I'll use that because it's actually kind of good tasting.
So.
And do you survive by bringing your own tea with you on tour?
I often do.
I haven't this time around I actually have a little travel tea kettle.
That's how desperate I am a,
but I did not bring it on this tour because it's so long.
Uh,
and I packed with extreme efficiency and there was no way that little kettle was
getting in there.
Cause if you're looking for some,
there's a t bar through.
Oh,
thank you.
Thank you very much.
Does
I think we have time for another question?
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
So you have a book,
your first book with literally justice in the title and are fairly active about
social issues on Twitter.
Uh,
how does that kind of affect both,
you know,
your writing and your professional life?
So,
uh,
I actually,
I,
you're right,
I am active with social issues and stuff on Twitter.
Uh,
lately it's a lot of angry re tweeting,
but,
uh,
I don't start out saying I want to write a book about this social issue.
Um,
I always start out saying,
I want to write a book with,
with this fun thing with the spider Max in it with a,
you know,
a ships to take over human bodies with space battles,
right?
Because who doesn't love space battles?
And,
um,
and then because I am frankly easily bored,
uh,
I need to have something to really think about while I'm working on a project.
I get very unsatisfied with things that are just lots of noise.
You know,
sometimes that's what you want to read.
But if I'm going to write a book,
I need to have more to think about.
Uh,
and it's then at that point I start digging into the motifs and the things that
I'm writing about.
And it's difficult for me not to think about,
uh,
my politics,
right?
How that intersects with what the story is saying.
Uh,
I personally believe that narrative is extraordinarily powerful,
uh,
because it's a basic mode of human thought.
It's how we analyze the world around us and the narratives that we have in our
inventory influence how we're going to respond to the world.
We see a thing and we're like,
we need to make a pattern out of that.
Here's a pattern.
Here's a template.
All right?
Everything fits.
And then you act according to that.
Uh,
and sometimes if you,
you can pick a template that can literally end up with somebody getting killed.
Uh,
and I would never tell writers to write particular kinds of stories,
but I feel that as a writer,
it's very important to think about the stories that I'm putting out because
those are potentially people's templates.
Uh,
and I don't want to be saying something that I would regret having said.
so I do think very hard about those things when I write the story,
but I don't sit down to write a story that tells somebody about my political
beliefs about something,
if that makes sense.
Sure.
Thank you.